okay so the boys are back in town and
the first three episodes have just
dropped on amazon
as i'm sure you can tell i'm as hyped as
hell to get into the series
and throughout this video we're going to
be going over the first three entries
and breaking down everything that you
need to know about them there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check them out yet then
i highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
as well as we'll be doing breakdowns on
the show week by week
and you don't want to miss any of them
anyway without the way
this is the heavy spoiler show i'm your
host definition
now let's get into the boys
okay so season two picks up immediately
after the events of the prior entry
with this joining the vote board led by
stan edgar
edgar is the ceo of war industries and
the man behind compound bees production
in america
stillwell originally reported to him
before she met her
her timely end and in her absence he's
came in and taken control of the company
compound v has been leaked to the public
and these opening episodes
very much deal with the fallout of the
world learning that the good guys
aren't actually that good now i do think
that the show is building towards a
rivalry between edgar and homelander
edgar actually appoints storm from
behind his back and this it's clear that
he views the seven as objects that he
can control and manage
rather than actual people that should
have opinions and input
juxtaposing this homelander views
himself as the talent
that can still survive without the
company which i think will cause a
conflict between the pair
i actually think that edgar purposely
chose stonefront because he knew that
the two would come into conflict with
one another
and this would lead to him having other
options so that the big boy didn't
become more powerful in the company
elsewhere black noir is hunting down the
soup terrorists
all the way out in syria this idea of a
super terror
villain becomes more prevalent
throughout the three episodes and it's
definitely worth focusing on
noir gets badly burned during this and
he could hint at the show
deviating from the comics in his true
identity i don't want to spoil anything
just yet
but basically he has the same power set
as homelander in the source
material and thus him getting burned
does tease that they are taking things
in a new direction
next we jump to translucent's funeral
and i found this
absolutely hilarious as is basically a
completely clear coffin
which is meant to show the character's
invisible body however
he's not actually there and there's
definitely a feeling that the show has
its tongue placed firmly in its cheek
translucent was of course blown to
smithereens in the first season
but as no one can see him anyway vort
have carried out the ceremony to the
public
to make it seem like he didn't die
horribly homelander uses his death as a
platform
to make it seem like translucent wanted
the soup terrorists hunted down
but as we know that wasn't the case and
it very much hammers home the fact that
the seven are all about image
rather than the truth we as viewers can
see through the entire thing
and there is a touch of irony as
translucent was of course invisible
and we could see through him speaking of
the invisible man
have you seen the invisible man you have
what did he look like anyway we really
see the juxtaposition between the boys
and the seven
with annie getting undressed in a luxury
room whilst huey is forced to live in an
underground squalor
due to being an outlaw we see the
translucent movies discussed by seth
rogen
and also witness how billy butcher has
been framed for the death of stillwell
this is hosted by chris henson who isn't
having a good time at the moment in real
life
and yeah this part this part of the show
hasn't aged well
but yeah billy joel's sung pressure
plays in the background
and another song by the pop artist pops
up throughout the second
and third entry the first song obviously
highlights how huey is under pressure
and we see the seven pretty much in all
aspects of society as he journeys
outside
the second song is your only human and
this of course highlights the
relationship between him and annie
notice i'm calling her annie and not
starlight and this name is purposely
highlighted throughout the first three
episodes
to show that she's drifting more towards
being a human as opposed to her persona
as a hero
the music video itself also sent his
around joel stopping someone jumping off
a bridge
as he convinces them they'll get a
second win and this ironically comes in
the second episode
which sees a real turnaround in the
character another person having a hard
time with his life as a hero
is the deep after being ostracized from
the group last season
he goes on one of the strangest arcs in
the show
there's also mention of the mariana
trench and i think that this might be a
call back to aquaman
as he mentions that it's not that fun
swimming in it in the movie the trench
was the point in which one of the
movie's most famous scenes happened
and it could be a nod to that as the
deep is of course a parody of the
character
through this he's reintroduced to eagle
the archer and we also watch as
homelander meets blind spot
now these are of course both plays and
popular heroes
eagerly archer though similar to green
arrow is
definitely spoofing hawkeye because of
his name
captain captain obvious here blind spot
on the other hand
is clearly daredevil and we learn that
the character was chosen because fort
are trying to seem inclusive
a lot of corporations at the moment are
being criticized for just
appearing to be inclusive in order to
make money
one of the most notable examples of this
which is often brought up
is disney who had an entire south park
episode
dedicated to their actions disney are
openly saying how much they're pushing
for acceptance of their characters
and yet when they marketed the force
awakens and avengers end game to china
the promotional material played down the
black characters
even reducing the size of john boyega on
the poster
it's quite smart commentary and it
doesn't beat you over the head with it
either
which makes me think that they're aware
of how things are and just want to say
this is pretty much
how our world is without offering up too
much of an opinion on it
homelander basically bursts blind spot
eardrums completely
and refuses to allow anyone to enter the
seven without his permission
as mentioned stormfront is hired to fill
the void
and this of course will cause a lot of
issues going ahead
stormfront of course ticks the boxes of
being female
and this is actually a meta joke as in
the comics the character was a man
gender swapping is also something that's
criticized when companies seem to want
to appeal to females
and i think that it's quite a smart
trick to carry this out all whilst
playing out the trope
they pretty much hammer home the notion
that she's a woman but laboring the
point that women are strong
which does hint that the creative team
view this tactic as something devised
purely for pr
rather than being a sincere choice
ayakash who plays the character is also
jewish
and this casting has clearly been done
because the original stormfront
was actually actually a bad guy from
world war
ii sorry i can't say what the word
really is
because of monetization on youtube
anyway in the source material
stormfront was actually created by the
germans during the war
and became drafted into their youth
program now these ties to the second
world war
are reworked with frederick bought who
we learn was a german scientist that
discovered compound v
due to hitler supplying him with
subjects hitler was of course obsessed
with creating a master race of aryan
supermen
and vault was at the forefront of this
in the original work
hitler ordered the extermination of
stormfront when he was very
young but he was helped by the allies as
was like the vort
who of course created the character
stormfront was brought into the group
but because of his upbringing he hated
other ethnicities
and saw himself as superior to all his
origin
story was reworked by vort who promoted
him as a viking
because of his powers these powers have
carried across the stormfront's tv
adaptation
and she has the ability of flight and
electrokinesis which means she can
control electricity
i also kind of get the feeling that
she's a play on storm from the x-men
but at least she's not doing terrible
toe jokes so i guess she's not all that
bad
i'm just kidding she's terrible at the
end of the third episode she destroys an
apartment complex
just to get someone and you very much
get the feeling that she symbolizes that
both sides of the political spectrum
have their extremists that will do
whatever they can just to get a win
there's also a mention of soldier boy in
one of the episodes
and as we know he's been confirmed for
the third season and will be played by
jensen ackles
soldier boy is basically a homicidal
captain america
and due to him being around in the war
it could be possible that he's been
frozen
similar to steve rogers and this will
explain how he arrives in the present at
the same age
that's just a theory though anyway all
this hiring angus homelander
and slowly things start collapse around
him but you know what
deep down i'm not even sure that he
minds the chaos that much
now billy's worth with the cia gets him
out of the hot spot that he was left in
last season
but i did feel like what happened was
slightly brushed over
and was expecting a bit more in terms of
the rivalry between himself
homelander and of course his wife who he
believed was dead
now his wife becker is clearly being
held captive by homelander
so all of the theories about her being a
willing participant
do fall apart when we see that she's
pretty much held hostage by the
antagonist
to me this is basically a comment on how
powerful men often bring women into
their lives through the promise of
wealth and power
but they then hold them prisoner a lot
of epstein's victims said that he was
almost impossible
to escape because of his resources and i
think this is really well mirrored in
homeland his actions
the pair of course have a child together
so not only is there trappings due to
his power
but also because of their offspring it
becomes clear that he's only keeping her
around to act as a mother for when he's
not there
and yeah their relationship becomes very
afraid
now we all know who their son ryan sides
with but homeland
realizes that he can get a reaction out
of him by abusing becker
another big returning character in the
series is a train and you might remember
at the end of the last season
it did seem like he was at death's door
however here we learn that the character
survived his heart attack
but he's still not up to speed pun
intended
he of course knows about annie and
worries that she will make the money dry
up which he
fears due to coming from poverty a train
has basically been running away from his
past
and he'll do whatever he can to not go
back there in the first season
a train was a bit of a jerk but here
we do see another side to him this is
merida in the deep
who gets far more character development
and even seems remorseful
at points over his actions i still think
he's a douche
but his fall from grace is fascinating
to watch
billy's cia contact is taken out by vore
in a super shocking moment
i do think that this will sell the
agency taking down the corporation at
some point
the seven will then be free agents and
if you thought that they were bad before
imagine when they're off the leash now
the second episode predominantly centers
around the boys capturing a super
villain
he just so happens to be kimiko's
brother and this sets up a revenge plot
when stormfront kills him
as you can guess their location is
discovered and the deep
trying to get back in the good books
swarms them but this ends pretty badly
with his spear-headed campaign getting
spearheaded itself by a speedboat
huey even ends up in the world's stomach
and this is of course a play on
pinocchio
in that the titular character famously
ended up in a whale's stomach
as he tried to become a real boy this is
probably a reach but
huey very much feels like he's in unreal
circumstances
and he's trying to obtain a position of
normality amongst the chaos that he's
found himself in
huey is a civilian and throughout there
is this motif that is just
in over his head he even almost
sacrifices himself
in order to allow annie to stay
undercover and yet
the guy's got a lot going on on top of
this the deep
very much represents someone who is
cancelled for absolutely heinous things
that's trying to claw their way back
kevin spacey was probably the first
major incident of a high-profile
celebrity
being completely shut down and since
then he's tried to pop up
time and time again in order to win
people back round
like spacey when the deep does it it
just doesn't work
and he becomes more and more desperate
to get back into the public eye
this eventually leads to him
hallucinating that the voice of patton
oswalt
is talking through his girls and his
consciousness gets a personality
oswalt was originally thought to be a
character that pretty much had an
encyclopedic knowledge of the seven
but i'm glad they did something
surprising with him the deep doesn't see
himself as he actually is
and this lack of awareness not only goes
to him not giving himself girls and
drawings
but also how the world should handle him
he believes he's a hero
but we know the reality of the situation
is far different
and that he shouldn't be viewed the way
that he sees himself as
he practically sings you are so
beautiful to me to himself
showing that he's accepted no real
accountability
for what he's done now the third episode
is really focused on the idea of family
and homeland slash becker's son and also
kimako and her brother
as for the former i actually have a
theory that it isn't homeland as child
at all
and that the kid might still be billies
but it was injected with compound b
and thus homelander believes that it's
his i think this would massively mess
him up
and we are clearly being led to believe
that they are related because of his
abilities
however his nature is the complete
opposite to his apparent father
might be true might not be true but you
know
we have to try and see these things from
other angles
we learned that he's been kept in a cage
his entire life overseen by bought
and i like his mother he's pretty much a
prisoner billy goes to the cia
and he makes a deal with the agency that
if they manage to bring in a super
terrorist
their records will be wiped clean they
discover kimiko's brother who i'm
calling kimmerbro
and their relationship is actually one
of the strong points in the opening
three entries
elsewhere annie's contact smuggles her
some compound b
and though he initially seems bad he's
pretty
harmless hey having that a train starts
to close in on her
and threatens to expose what she's up to
but after she reveals that she knows he
killed his girlfriend
we realize that he's not interested in
the truth only himself
now empires are only ever brought down
from the inside and seeing that the pair
knows secrets about one another
does tease at how the downfall of the
seven will be
on top of this we learn why maeve keeps
a relationship quiet too
as we discover that the possessive
homelander killed someone
for just trying to make a move on her
this of course is reflected in becker
who wants nothing more than to have him
out of her and his son's life
i think they might actually use ryan as
a way to fight the character
and homelander caring for the boy is the
[ __ ] in his armor that the heroes won't
be above exploiting
however that doesn't mean that the boys
have it easy and stormfront seems like
someone that's gonna cause a lot of
issues for them
after stormfront kills kimmer bro you
can tell that his sister wants revenge
however homelander clearly doesn't like
her either i actually think that he's
been keeping billy alive for reasons
exactly like this and that he will in
fact kill a character but make it look
like the boys did it so that they take
the fall
i think the boys will then use becca to
fight back as it's one of the things
that homelander is most possessive over
she's gonna be the main thing that both
sides want to get and this will
inevitably lead to ryan
being brought to the forefront we know
which side ryan will end up on
but whether homeland elects him or not
is a completely different question
billy and co of course need to actually
locate where he is
and i think the next big mission that
they go on will be finding this facility
anyway that concludes the first three
entries and i know this wasn't as
thorough as say
my love craft country breakdowns but
with it being three hours long
i didn't want the video to spiral into a
massive 50 minute long one where i break
down every single scene bit by bit
with the episodes being weekly though
from now on things will be a lot more in
depth
but i hope you enjoyed it anyway maybe
i'm just being too hard on myself
now as always i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the season so far so comment
below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of raised by wolves
which is going to be linked at the end
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of september
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below you can
also come chat us on the discord server
linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you